les chéris vous avez vu alors le salaire
de nelson monfort 5000 euros parce que
j'ai pas trop le temps là dessus c'est
roux s'est passé que
les visions franchement ma voix c'est
très bien sûr ça correct il a un emploi
quand même très sécure il n'est pas non
plus tous les jours à l'antenne voilà
moi je trouve que c'est très bien
c'est très bien c'est un vieux pardon
mais enfin j'aime beaucoup j'aime
beaucoup non seulement forme enfin il
fait il fait deux semaines de
roland-garros il faut deux tonnes de
pâte et artistique et le résultat est
chez lui sert et 60000 euros par an
c'est quand même pas mal vrai ce
qui fait il ali leïla mais vous faites
ça pour tous les chroniqueurs ici
je dirais c'est pas lourd mais en vrai
il bosse si semaine d'après
ils croient pas au bras il travaille
fait coiffer par
gueugnon me prépare oui ces belles
choses chez mondrian arrêter d'être
démago oui cinq mille euros c'est énorme
et beaucoup de gens mais en télé c'est
un petit
rayon rédaction torres ça se paye son
image sa cible et
de laisser sa chance au produit isabelle
salaire est correct mais pardon il ya
aussi toutes les invitations à côté moi
je me suis souvent retrouvé les endroits
sa cote est de la semaine à côté en
valeur mirail à côté de la coupe la
merci mejia côtés d'acapela merci oui
avec guillaume s'est passé pas une 3-2
privait c'est de l'argent public donc
salon euros c'est un très très beau ça
devrait évidemment c'est moins que
d'autres mais c'est pas non plus une
mégastar m de montfort c'est un
animateur
n'est pas du tout un peuple est était
très très différemment d'un photon le
car qui n'ont pas le garder sa notoriété
qui gagne 1 sur 15
vision tout le monde gagne plus de 5000
euros par mois et tous les
boss en rédaction sport il fait plein
d'événements etc et puis là il a une
longue carrière
pasquale moi excusez moi car ma montiel
qu'il faut quand même faire parler un
petit peu dans l'émission mais ça se
paie la connaissance et le savoir bien
sûr le mec qui maîtrise ses dossiers
ouais il est parfait tous les joueurs de
tennis le connaissent tous les patineurs
le connaissent donc il est des
interviews qui sont toujours
intéressantes parce qu'il maîtrise est
très basse et bien
c'est bien oui sociale d'informer temps
comme salaire c'est beaucoup trop
c'est un salaire net sur le service et
net je veux que dans les services
publics avec quelques semaines
effectivement par an pour un journaliste
il est journaliste dans ces
invraisemblables sert il
d'être
moi j'ai pas commencé c'est toi
apparemment très doit commencer à dire
que les abeilles ou pas s'est payée le
toit du bordelais le tien mais moi j'ai
déjà donné plein de fois ici ah ben je
suis bon je reconnais pas un nazi vous
m'avez augmenter cette année
et d'ailleurs et d'à petits matins on
nous a tous très mal d'années
biko vide
cocagne
je vous le dis j'ai pas peur de le dire
ici et je suis prêt à vous regarder
chacun droit dans les yeux vous dire je
vais guérir l'argent à cause de
jeu continuera à le faire pour vous
aider
le seul que je peux regarder dans les
yeux en disant ça c'est castaldi est ce
que je sais
c'est vrai que ton en nous disant ça
vous avez quel lien de parenté avec
kayak est ce que ça vous or je connais
pas alors que les loups payzac voilà qui
s'appelle bruno queysanne et
je voulais vous remercier parce que vous
m'avez même dit le budget est serré mais
pour récompenser un travail je
t'augmente et je baisse les autres merci
[Applaudissements]